there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
[Applause]
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do i know you
[Applause]
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
oh
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my dune trailer video
the sleeper must awaken so there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here i'll
explain what they're doing with this
movie and how they're covering the story
from the first book of dune
because this is just meant to be the
first half of the story of course i'll
be doing videos for the dune series so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we'll do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
so we'll just start at the beginning of
the trailer and work our way through
shot by shot talk about easter eggs as
we go along
most of you have probably seen or read
at least some of the dune's story or
encountered it at some point in the past
one of the most shared memed moments
from any of the dunes series the books
is that opening prologue from the 1984
movie
arrakis dune desert planet with virginia
madsen's opening prologue scene
the funny thing about the song that they
put on this too is it's actually pink
floyd from dark side of the moon so this
is a bit of a wink and a clever easter
egg on the concept of arrakis dune
desert planet that's the way that the
book opens that's the way the david
lynch's 1984 movie opened
they sort of skip over that for the
opening of this trailer because it opens
with his dream as he wakes up and he's
talking to the benny jesuit reverend
mother about the visions that he's
having of the future without
understanding that he's having visions
of the future he has all this power that
he doesn't know about yet
the sleeper must awaken he's effectively
talking about that in his voiceover at
the beginning of the trailer
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind
as he has this vision of shawnee and the
sun
rising while they're on arrakis so
obviously this is all scenes from later
in the movie but it's visions that he's
having at the very beginning of the
movie
when he talks about seeing the crusade
coming that's obviously the civil war
that happens on arrakis when the
harkonnens come for them after they're
betrayed by dr yui and the bani jesuit
reverend mother
then they give you the scene of the
famous test obviously that's a big
moment during the 1984 film it's a big
moment during the books
the reverend mother has come to kaladan
to test him to see if he has the power
that they think that he has if he's
going to become the quiz at
the result of ten thousand years of
selective breeding to create a perfect
being to lead humanity on the golden
path
away from their demise while he is the
protagonist of the movie the main
character
the important thing to remember though
is that he's not the most important
character at the beginning of the story
one of the biggest characters who's
driving the story itself
before the events of the movie pick up
is actually his mother lady jessica
and a lot of her choices inform the
really big moves that the plot has
during the story
especially early on his mother lady
jessica was actually born to the
harkinan family but she's a member of
the bennett jesuit order
and they ordered her to marry duke leto
and give him a daughter
so that they could wed that daughter to
a hearkening prince and in this
long-running feud within the galaxy
so the whole thing is they do want to
bring peace and lead humanity forward
it's just that the benny jesuit order
wants to be in control of that person
that perfect being
but lady jessica winds up falling in
love with him and gives him a son that
he wants
so that's where paula treatise comes in
he becomes the vessel for all this power
that the ban of jesuit has been
orchestrating
so the river mother has come to see
what's actually going on with him that's
why she's asking him these questions do
you often have visions of things that
come to pass
the concept of genetic memory is very
important to the dune mythology
the reverend mother at any given time of
the bennett jesuit order possesses
sort of like the sum total of all
knowledge and memories from previous
generations
but paula tradies becoming the quiz at
satorac also gains all those memories
when he says i can see the future that's
actually part of his powers is the quiz
at saturac he can actually see the
golden path but the whole thing about
all this power that's bestowed on him is
that it actually becomes a bit of a trap
i don't know if they're gonna deal with
this during the movie they'll probably
address it at some point
but he himself becomes sort of trapped
within his own destiny and it becomes a
big problem for him later on
lady jessica also winds up giving birth
to a little girl aaliyah
after duke lido has died and she also
gains those powers when she takes in the
waters of life
so effectively you have two characters
with the powers of the quizadz sadarack
in the dunes series
obviously most of the trailer is just
focusing on the first half of the story
though with him meeting the sand worms
the sleeper must awaken that big iconic
moment from the 1984 film
that's sort of the moment when he
eventually takes the waters of life and
his powers start to awaken within him he
becomes conscious of his abilities
one of the differences between this film
and the 1984 film though
is that the david lynch movie blew
through a lot of the plot within that
one movie
so you have to imagine that most of this
will encompass the big civil war that
happens on arrakis
him meeting the frem and meeting chani
and learning about his powers
then the second half of the story will
be what he does once he unlocks those
abilities
i love the scene of him putting his hand
in the box everybody remembers this from
the 1984 film
fear is the mind killer as he slowly
starts to sense all these crazy things
happening to it
this is the same scene from the 1984
film of him fighting with gurney played
by josh brolin
thanos himself oscar isaac who's playing
duke lido made all kinds of josh brolin
jokes when the cast was doing their big
interview for the movie earlier
gurney's sort of their warmaster he's
the one that's teaching paul to fight
before all the craziness of the actual
plot of the story their whole idea is
that eventually one day
paul will take over the family once duke
lido dies of natural causes obviously
that doesn't wind up happening
but gurney is one of his most important
teachers early on before all this
happens
when the bene jesuit mother is talking
to him about learning to rule himself
and rule others
obviously that's all just foreshadowing
for later in the movie once he becomes
the most powerful person
in the universe it's also a bit of
foreshadowing for the eventual god
emperor of dune story which isn't
something that paul tradies gets too
involved in that's all about the golden
path leading humanity forward
i think everyone's kind of hoping that
if the movies are really successful
they'll actually do the story of his son
duke leto ii who becomes god emperor of
dune
is a giant giant tv series when the
reverend mother is talking about his
father
losing the planet she's foreshadowing
the events of the big betrayal that's
going to be happening later in the movie
so it's not that they hate duke lido and
they want to get rid of house of tradies
it's just that they feel like the only
way to achieve this golden path now
based on current events is to throw him
under the bus
i love the production design i love the
look of the sand worms everything looks
great obviously they tried to go back to
a lot of the original frank herbert
dune concept art for their designs
really cool easter egg here too when
their ships are landing on arrakis
don't these look a little bit like jawa
sand crawlers so if you're not a huge
fan of the dunes
series what you might not realize is is
that george lucas was actually
inspired by a lot of what frank herbert
did with that first dune book
when he was writing the star wars
stories and doing the original trilogy
but really it's not them trying to do
star wars with dune the reason why it
looks a little bit like star wars is
because star wars itself was inspired by
that original dune stuff
we get our first look at the beast
played by dave batista i'm sure he's
going to be
a amazing monster during the movie we
get our first look at stellen skarsgard
who's playing baron harkin himself
as we see them landing on the planet we
meet jason momoas duncan idaho for the
first time
he's actually one of the first people as
part of the duke's forces to meet the
freeman when the emperor tells duke lido
that he is now in charge of spice
production and has to move his family to
arrakis he sends duncan idaho there
ahead of their forces to sort of get the
lay of the land
what a lot of people don't realize
though is that early in the story the
planet arrakis
itself is one of the most important
characters in the dunes story through
all of the dune novels because of its
relationship with the sand worms and the
spice itself
is it's the sand worms themselves that
create the spice that's so critical to
the function of the universe
they use it for faster than light travel
it has all kinds of medicinal properties
all kinds of psychedelic properties it's
sort of like this wonder drug that does
so many different things but it's only
produced on this one planet
but most of the universe does not
realize that the sand worms themselves
are what create the spice so it's really
the sand worms themselves they're the
most important resource
in the universe and when the reverend
mother says one day the legend will be
born
all of civilization depends on it she's
actually talking about
paul's son she's not talking about paul
himself but i don't know if they're
actually going to get to that in any of
the movies they might save that for an
eventual children of dune series
if you're wondering why there's not a
whole lot of zendaya's chaney character
in this trailer there's a lot of shots
of her early on but she said that she's
not really big during this first part of
the story she's probably gonna be a much
bigger character during the sequel
that's just because he doesn't really
encounter her until after this big
revolt and it sounds like that's going
to take up most of the events of this
first movie
i love the reveal of the sand worms too
does this not look so much like the
original concept art and it just gives
you an idea for the scale of things just
how
massive the sand worms can get but
everyone let me know in the comments
what you're most hyped up about this is
obviously just a small part of the story
like i said this is going to be a
two-part story for the first book
the movie is supposed to come out in
december hopefully theaters will all be
open everywhere and we can actually go
to a theater and see it
but there'll be more trailers in the
next couple of months so of course i'll
do videos when they drop that new
footage
everyone click here for my brand new
chadwick boseman black panther video
and click here for that brand new
mandalorian season 2
teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight
you